any questions are coming if you have to
take off take off well then let me again
repeat this idea that you're not just a
collector of techniques you are trying
to acquire skill it's the difference
between information and talent right you
can read how to swim
is it swimming no so you can talk all
day about blending with sube right you
have to be able to do it how do you how
does one acquire a skill how strangely
by not talking about it because talking
gets in the way of doing do you
understand
but can you just do whatever no you're
trying to acquire a particular skill
there is a difference between swimming
and not drowning do you understand so if
you're reading a book on swimming or
you're studying a swimming technique
it's not enough just to keep your head
above water
and dog paddle to the end of the pool
and say at least I didn't drown and
that's not good enough
musubi is high high level it's far from
dog paddle do you understand far from
dog paddling sitting there and doing
rope-a-dope
that's dog paddling covering yourself up
staying on the line attacker bracing for
impact
that's dog paddling look at all the
things that you have to do to make it
seem like it's functioning you got to
get weapons out you got to get weight
categories you need a starting pal you
need a raft
you can talk paddle in a pool can you do
it in the ocean can you do it in a storm
no you're going to drown it'll be as if
you know nothing
so you can't just talk about connection
musubi that's you as a
practitioner have to understand okay I
got the information and now I have the
direction and now it's all about doing
all about practicing this is why we say
hey daily practice daily practice why do
most people all over the world train
three two times a week because it's
information based then it makes sense if
you're in the University my schedule I
got Tuesday Thursday uncle men Monday
Wednesday Friday you know which classes
didn't do that language classes music
classes right and the hard was a
language that means the further it was
away from English you were there five
days in the class then they gave you all
those tapes you had to study right and
you had to hang out with all your
friends and you had to try to look who
speak English
I needs to be pissed because the Spanish
students four days a week
Japanese five what it's not worth that
extra credit right do you guys remember
this and you know what I was lured in
Japanese you know five hours a week
guess why didn't cut it did not cut it
hey Berkeley's got a summer intensive on
them guess what five hours a day guess
what didn't cut it I'm gonna have to go
lives are
that was just a dumbass language you're
talking about awakened movement do you
understand this is crazy
crazy difference to expect that you're
going to get it without the reps the
reps the reps over and over and over and
over again you have to understand that
so you need this abundance I understand
there's a difference between information
and skill got it
now what sensei okay got it
I need an abundance I needed abundance
now what okay I can't waste any of my
abundance on crap
I had a friend I don't know he there was
there was a word to go and he would go
check out check out in Japanese check
out it's like it's not snow how you say
it and he would say it everywhere and
guess what every Japanese person would
say hmm just no one could understand him
it was a waste of rep dude you're saying
it wrong there's no owl oh oh no I'll
stop saying out so here you are
don't cut on their arm you just wasted
you've wasted a wrap
don't push on their head
you're wasting your wrap put as much of
yourself in the technique in the rep so
that you don't waste them so that they
become actual repetitions of what you're
trying to do here's the kicker that is
the spiritual practice if you do not
cast yourself with that perfect
repetition then you do not need your
entire presence there you do not need
your entire being there you can have
your mind wandering wherever you want
you can be distracted and hesitant
without center without presence do you
see what does it matter between all the
variants of wrong they're all the same
what does it matter whether you're there
or not but to task yourself with that
right rep now you have a spiritual
practice
to demand of yourself I will do it that
way and that way only now you're
training both martially and spiritually
do you understand this is what I mean
when I colloquially say it's not a
free-for-all free-for-all for me is like
darkness that's how you have to see it
and I can't make you do that can I make
you do that no I can't you just have to
stop not caring but you can everyone can
everyone can I'm not saying it's easy
but everyone can do that
everyone can stop practicing not caring
and get it get it
get it